in
five billion years we're going to have a
hefty problem on our hands
well only if we're still living on earth
at this point
our sun will be on the brink of collapse
if we don't find a way to give it all
the fuel it needs
well we're toast how could
jupiter help us refuel the sun
what other stars have consumed gas
giants
and what would life be like without
jupiter
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we refueled the sun with jupiter
the sun's delicate balance of hydrogen
and helium
keeps us alive and well
although you might think there's an
infinite ball of energy up there
i hate to break it to you but the sun's
not sticking around forever
in order to keep it going our sun needs
a consistent source of hydrogen
at its core the sun's hydrogen is
converted to helium in the process of
nuclear fusion
this fusion reaction is exothermic
meaning
it gives off more energy than it
consumes
this energy is released as gamma
radiation
which provides enough of an outward push
of gravity
to keep the sun from imploding
so how exactly can jupiter help with all
this
well about 90 percent of jupiter's
atmosphere
is made of hydrogen this makes it
one big ball of fuel even though it's
only
0.01 percent the mass of the sun
[Music]
astronomers have located a sun similar
to ours that
has been eating a jupiter-like gas giant
called wasp-12b good one science
i hate wasps too wasp-12b's atmosphere
is being sucked up by its star forming a
hot ring of gas around it
as its atmosphere is pulled outward this
is making the planet puff up to six
times the size of jupiter
our sun gobbles up hydrogen at a rate of
620 million metric tons
per second with four gas giants in our
solar system
we could keep the sun sizzling for
another 87
million years with jupiter being the
biggest
we'd probably want to start there in
order to pull this off
we'd need to set up jupiter like
wasp-12b
close enough to the sun to deliver a
constant influx
of hydrogen from its atmosphere it would
have to be
just enough hydrogen so that no mass is
added or lost from the sun in other
words
like a healthy diet and exercise with an
occasional cheat day
but couldn't we just smash jupiter into
the sun
that sounds like more fun to me well
this would make for some good fireworks
but this would increase the sun's mass
too quickly causing it to burn hot
enough to turn global warming
into global roasting the key is to keep
the sun's mass
stable so its fusion remains consistent
at its core
even if we managed to nudge jupiter
close enough to the sun
that could lead to a whole slew of other
problems
because without jupiter's stable
gravitational pull
all of our planetary orbits including
earth's
would be thrown off course and
we'd lose our precious shield against
deadly asteroids and comets
so realistically we'd probably have to
suck it up and move somewhere else
who knows maybe there's a really nice
earth-like
exoplanet out there for us to settle
let's just hope it's not already
populated by
hungry aliens whatever the scenario is
that's a story for another
what if